we're getting a look at what happened
inside the deliberation room as a jury
decided to convict Harvey Weinstein of
two felony sex crimes only on CBS this
morning we spoke to drew juror number
nine in the New York trial that lasted
five weeks he asked us not to use his
last name so we won't Drew said that the
Weinstein jury took the five day long
deliberation process very seriously
coming to a unanimous verdict required a
close look at the legal definition of
the charges it wasn't rape in the first
degree he there was no physical
compulsion with the threat of bodily
harm or death and but there was no
consent given despite a lack of physical
resistance and a reasonable person
should have known that there was no
consent given in that instance juror
number nine also known as drew says
Jessica man's testimony was compelling
enough for a guilty verdict of
third-degree rape but not enough to
convict Harvey Weinstein of the most
serious charges he was facing man
testified that Weinstein sexually
assaulted her several times during their
years long on-and-off-again relationship
her testimony was very emotional how did
that affect you on a personal level it
affected me very deeply but that's not
what we were there to do we were there
to do a job and to interpret the law and
make a make a decision based on evidence
and on testimony the testimony that
women can be sexually assaulted but
still maintain contact with their
attacker that didn't factor into your
decision at all in the earlier parts of
the deliberation there was huge
discourse about things of that nature I
asked because so many people have
trouble understanding that did that
factor into your decision making process
the decision making though it's an
alleged incident not kind of this whole
canvas of relationship it's you know
husbands can rape their wives and it's a
complicated issue for sure but it was
our contention that that's it's one
incident three of the five charges
stemmed from man's accusations the other
two focused on Miriam Haley a former
production assistant who
justified Weinstein sexually assaulted
her in his apartment in 2006 men and
Haley both took the sand after Sopranos
actress Annabelle Ashera testified as
the prosecution tried to show a pattern
of behavior to the jury one of the
charges was predatory sexual sure and he
was found not guilty on that and the
supporting testimony of Annabelle Ashura
compelling in and of itself but these
are serious allegations and that's a
very high burden that the prosecution
took upon itself and bringing these
charges it's 27 years ago and in this
country you know you and I and and and
even Harvey Weinstein are innocent until
proven beyond the reasonable doubt of
the opposite did it influence you one
way or the other that Harvey Weinstein
did not take the stand I wanted him to
and I could hypothesize as to the whys
that he didn't you know that he could
lose kind of his shield of
representation once he goes up there did
that influence your decision-making that
he did or did not know because the only
thing that influenced mine and our
collective decision-making was what we
had in front of us
last Friday jurors sent a note to the
judge asking if they could be split on
some counts but unanimous on others drew
explained the jury was simply looking
for clarification but outside the court
he said it was mistaken as a sign that a
verdict was imminent well maybe that's
our fault for the the syntax of the note
but but I I know now that people kind of
deduce that that maybe he was guilty
somewhere along the line and and I'll
tell you I was sick about it because
he's a human being and he's going home
that night and knowing that he's walking
into court Monday morning and
potentially not leaving you know
regardless of what any other human does
to any other humans for me to affect
another person like that really really
took a toll on me his defense team has
already made it clear they're going to
appeal this verdict do you think Harvey
Weinstein should go to jail that's not
for me to say okay you're not going to
be involved in the sentencing but you do
have an opinion you know like
say that once you think man of his age
and of his current health general
population that Riker sounds like a
pretty dangerous place it's really a lot
I could say about that so you know
there's been a lot of speculation about
what was the message the jury was trying
to send what is the message through that
there is there is no message we were
there to do a job to make a decision
based on the information that was
presented to us and we have absolutely
no stance or voice or opinion as to any
type of larger movement that didn't
factor into your decision at all zero he
was so impressive I can't stress this
enough he praised both the prosecution
and the defense he thought they both put
on a very strong case on depending on
the side that they were representing he
did say that the jury jurors were very
turned off when the prosecution
introduced that nude picture of Harvey
Weinstein you know he said we've all
seen mr. Weinstein none of us felt we
needed to see him new they were very
turned off by that and didn't think that
that helped the case but other than that
he thought that both sides put on a very
very strong case such incredible
discipline yeah I mean just think you
know he's from New Jersey he doesn't
want us to talk about you know his life
and what he does but to have never been
put in that position before and we'll
come together and to do what they did
I'm glad their goal was not to send a
message yes but they sent one yeah the
same time but they weren't trying to and
he's emphasizing that very emphatically
we were not trying to send a message we
were doing our jobs and they did